every Hammer blow gets this island one
step closer to normality
the slow painstaking challenge to
reconnect thousands of homes who've
endured their worst power outage in
decades lines strained unable to cope
with the weight and pressure the house
is this cold inside as it is outside
isn't it Angela has been cut off since
Monday a long week no heating no hot
water no phone signal so I've not been
able to contact anybody to let them know
that we're okay I've got a little
camping stove that I've been making cups
tea on and so in the evening we're just
sitting up there with loads and loads of
quilts and blankets I've got like two
jumpers on in my jacket Marlene's lived
here all her days never has she seen
anything like this I've been really
miserable
and yes about the stress
because the last time it happened my
husband was still alive and it was very
different
but when you're a 77 year old Widow on
your own that's a bit more than you know
much more difficult
and it's the vulnerable the agencies are
battling to help the longer this lingers
on using places like this to provide
food drinks and Company
this is one of the most remote
communities in the whole of the UK but
people here are resilient they're
gathering in these Emergency Shelters
powered by generators providing a
critical Lifeline at this incredibly
difficult time it just basically started
with my wife going around the doors for
a flask since then we need whole life
for a cup of tea because we've got gas
and then one of the other neighbors
tundrum and says well why don't you just
kind of we open up the hall we'll get
the gas going and it's escalated from
there it's been amazing I've not seen
Community Spirit like this in a long
long time and it's just been so
phenomenal to see everybody just kind of
coming together and just working
together officials here in Shetland hope
this major incident would draw to a
close this weekend now that is in doubt
possibly a small number of households
could go into next week without power
they're working hard to make sure that
doesn't happen but you're right to say
just get into some of these places
extremely difficult
a bleak thought on an island craving a
return to normal life an island dreading
any future repeats Connor Gillis Sky
News on Shetland